well then gentlemen welcome to the
biggest and best conversation in the
world according to the International
podcasting Federation of America ranked
we were right we just won number one
podcast of all time and I want to thank
the fans out there we just got our our 1
billion we get a billion downloads a
month obviously lines no I know a lot of
people think I'm lying but I'm not and I
just want to say that I'm humbled and
that I take full credit for it it's
already all going to be in hey hello
Leslie didn't broke you guys might
recognize them from Modern Family give
it up for Brian Calley [ __ ] I'm
not on Modern Family and then I came up
States I will it Brian get on stage yeah
I was reading in those days and he's
just keeping me he's boxing me out yeah
boy I couldn't get your gear up ever
wall playing some defense I was kind of
do a little armed dragon but it wasn't
working that's not a crowd either that
improv crowd they don't Oh how's the
Tommy story once I'm fun we're
high-fiving I'm wrong The Improv I see I
thought they were older under their
wailed or not am I kind of young and
kind of like you and I thought they're a
great crowd but they don't know us so
when they saw me [ __ ] with you
they're like oh my god what's happened
with the bully in the corner over there
buddy
kind of [ __ ] he's got his shoppers on
shallow lake shove is out yo big showers
these are my shoves if I were you I
would always pull my hands out sometimes
just for no reason where everybody's
kind of nice and go well time for my
shovers it's like God made you small
tell you you'd shove me around like God
gave you a bird and I did I stop and you
go no stop don't stop being small I bet
come on seriously stop and you go
stop being small let's say God make you
small well shred can't be a bully kutta
not though what Josh wolf is I mean they
were talked about last night have you
seen it with a stray dog
hey hey here's a you hey shut up man
maybe you will shut up all right here he
shut up about it that can we not Josh
wolf in his body compared to mine
Natalie dude I have a great body it's
all right
completely just woof oh he's actually
like don't hey wolf say wolf number one
number two don't like muscular don't say
so myself I hear do you know what I have
a winner
Johnson I have a better body no yes I do
have a better rod yes I do I wish yes I
do
um have you were taking your shirt off
and then had a night guy take your shirt
off and put your shirt back on cuz you
know I can see you being a little too
self-conscious no never no no what I
think my shirt alone why hey why would
anyone take this ribbon some guys I hey
man who in your life Solano my tits I
don't like my ten would put this shirt
on at the beach if there's one thing
scientists can't do is wear shirts at
the beach you're the kid in oh maybe
grew up weird but there's always the kid
who would wear a dress at pool that's
when we play volleyball you'll never see
him with a shirt off volleyballs dick
and I don't believe your volleyball
shit's flying around your sweaty titties
rolls I made in the pool parents listens
do not put your kid in a goddamn white
tee in the pool yeah it's a bad idea and
also it looks like a what wet t-shirt
gun is couldn't even see the titties
through the white well here's the things
you see the rolls at the back it just
like it literally it's like peacock and
then you get the fact with women a lot
of times what the giveaway is if I see a
girl is super hot but she's wearing a
sweater around her butt or she's wearing
a long shirt a lot of times that butt is
a little too flat nope see you [ __ ] up
mrs. C you're older so you'll have your
ear to the grindstone here your older
girls who have a man like so so my girl
has a ridiculous ass yes she puts a
sweater over her ass she will stop
traffic if she leaves that thing ham but
you know your girl you can see your girl
could be wearing like she could have a
tent around her ass and you'd still know
she had a nice yeah but most girls if
they do have like a blah ass and they
don't would be harassed if it is
sweaters over he is over like not even a
sec about Heil
we're almost like a UH like a you know
like a shirt like a like a jean shirt or
something over it so it is otherwise
when they walk by like obey mama like
that bullsh in Islam that they were
talking about these people were up in
arms are like women have to pray behind
the men it's it's not even egalitarian
and this Islamic scholar was like well
actually that was because when you
prostate yourself to pray to Allah you
women have to bend
/ and when they do that you know what
men would do young men is supposed to be
praying they'd be like no you get that
she's bending over and they were like
what the woman's behind the men
obviously because it may yeah of course
it makes sense certain little big things
like that that make total sense early uh
it's not about that yoga they even men
[ __ ] minds
Lynette what the hell do they don't do
that no yoga no I thought that your
instructor I gaze up front
gaze up front brendon gaze up front like
bro oh that's so unfair ro that's so
embarrassing
[ __ ] you were saw that guy I never went
back and then back
he started the class like this I haven't
been the hottie residence started yet
[ __ ] amateur hour call me out what the
[ __ ] jay-z you got me out for eyeball
you know he he is like he's the white
dude with dreads already like ah life
isn't going well so he has the dreads
he's all earthy do you have lotion on no
I'm have lotion good with for the best
quality experience no lotion no sense my
eyebrow just [ __ ] turn this goddamn
heat on and shut your yapper yeah so I
go in right and I'm doing my fingers I
just let everyone know there are no
water breaks you can only have water if
I tell you to have water and there's no
leave in the room once this doors locked
there's no gigging getting out that kind
of like that's a violation of it's not
right [ __ ] if it's because you're in
there for 90 minutes if I'm right here
I'm getting the [ __ ] out man so there's
hot girls everywhere it's [ __ ] yoga
the hottest girls the daughter if you go
to a yoga class in Santa Monica you're
surrounded by can see it it's ridic so
they do yes so I'm there to just get a
nice stretch on come on lower backer can
running so I'm on there I do my thing
and I'm bending down he's already I'm
like the only guy in there I can tell
he's like has this weird vibe with me
does this gaze up front but blending
gaze up front
hey man that that would hey bro crazy I
I went like this you shoot me I just lit
up though his when he's shooting me and
he's up front up front like oh my god I
slowly I haven't been back that that
that would be it's almost like you'd
want to wait for him afterwards and
rough him up shove him around
we pull you summers get out not put your
sharp a ninety-minute to the beasts
you're exhausted I get out and I'm sit
so I like to sit down and drink to cool
water everyone stalk and I were just
and gather my goddamn life and my
thoughts there yeah and then he comes by
and says you tell he's just like on
those is that your alpha move in the
yoga room and horse it was of course it
was it was gonna be a thing that it all
becomes that even though the girls were
like conflict is do you those guys those
guys are teaching yoga so they can have
sex with all the girls that's what
happens those dudes with the blonde
dreads don't please don't get it
confused he's not there to enlighten
anybody he's there to be a guru and put
it all in a position of authority so he
can bang the girls he want it when she
said to sit indian-style in the diksa
correct going on right but really
connect heart to heart this is the thing
though it touches all cleanliness
you know dreads or some of the most oh
yeah dirty things that human being
connect they did a thing on it that
where their beards are dirtier than
public toilets Red's do you think dreads
are nuclear then I'll wash them know
whatever they don't need a black dread
develop like out red yeah what in the
what what term did you go wrong they
always know the [ __ ] did that happen
every time I thought if I kiss Tiger was
16 had dreads like oh my god yeah oh my
god give myself a huge F for being they
always smell a little bit like dirt they
are like hummus yeah like like they were
like old hum like bad patchouli oil they
smell like spices they have herbs in
they smell like a combination of like
old like wood dirty would like like like
put your face put your nose against an
old church pew that people have been
sitting on forever and partying look
it's smoke those white dreads black
dreads are different for some like your
girl with black dread to see the
different easy
keep it clean yeah I celebrate that I
why but a white guy with dreads
it doesn't first of all no you can't do
that you know a lot of really bothers me
and you don't have the [ __ ] together
they smell like they can grew as petting
in [ __ ] Australis hey my daddy no
Farrell the word is Farrell like a
fairly no a cat goes feral when it's
wild it says if they smell like an alley
cat that you cotton it's like hurt and
yet you know well they're certain like
my friend or like GI Gabby's
Mediterranean food he left in your car
in the Sun is like hummus and falafel
when my friends I was on SNL with that
and my
now and Matthew McConaughey back in his
muscle days he was walking around with a
shirt off all the time the other day 19
body Boise house was yeah with his jeans
like his and they're all comedians they
could give us like come on amazing and
he's walking around with a shirt off I
swear to God all day with his because
there was one scene where he had to take
a shirt off
of course he's like well it's a little
hot in here so here's what I'm going to
shut off with his top button of his jean
unbuttoned and he smelled like you know
he just smelled a little strong a
rutting war and they were all like dude
it'd be oh yeah of course but you know
to scent it's his essence oh there's a
friend of mine who I'll tell you
afterwards
you know there's no [ __ ] person like
cool person funny is [ __ ] you love them
and deal but they were like they were
like this guy was so he was so obviously
peacocking that's why you always have a
problem but then I saw him in Bad
Lieutenant
and I whatever that dealt I was slow and
I was robbing now I like absolute Timmy
turn up trying to tag me whenever the
[ __ ] I had lieutenant our last box but
he was great in that and I new fans back
the iPad yeah yeah you remember fast
tenant remember bad first mom young
little bit one of the best movies period
he tells about it one of the best movies
ever how did you not I'm not the day if
you wanted a game 36 like this one oh it
doesn't matter you want to see an
amazing movie Harvey Keitel in Bad
Lieutenant
Oh Harvey Keitel and he's a [ __ ] cop
and he's like what's cool
it doesn't matter he's a cop in this
girl he pulls him over and there's a
scene where he's like you beautiful
girls you drinking I'm out to impound
your car
the girls like you can't do that he's
like yeah beautiful girls and you know
it's coming honey please but impound
your car listen to me I'm gonna take you
can't please I need it for work yeah
yeah beautiful girls I'm leaving for a
bite and then he's sitting there and
he's like so you ever suck a [ __ ] no we
don't do anything he goes yeah you're
doing you ever suck a [ __ ] you hit him
he girls like yeah and he goes yeah yeah
show me how you suck a [ __ ] and she's
like what and he's like show me your
mouth
she's like you stick your tongue out he
was you turn around turn around look out
the window but show me your ass
show me your ass he started clobbered at
all
where's the cherries like yeah show me
come on doctor it's so [ __ ]
disturbingly watch that scene you know
[ __ ] you like shelves off oh my god when
it came out we were all like what like
and you know it's happened a weap Artie
Lange and I you know a friend of his we
knew a cop and this is the story he was
telling he's like he's like he came to
visit us the first year at MADtv and he
he was this big Irish kid from Jersey
nice guy but he is saying he was saying
he's like look man I pulled this girl
over she was drinking now here's the
thing I drink and drive so you know I
don't want to be a hypocrite but I'm
like what do you do for a living honey
she's like I work you know as I'm
currently doing because we can kiss that
job with goodbye she's not gonna get
your car man impound your car
the thing is I'm talking her and she's
[ __ ] hot so she's like walk what can
I do I'll do anything as well all right
gotta take care of the kid and
apparently she blew him in the back of
his squad I'll see you he got by the way
he's back he was a dirty cop he got
fired yes got he didn't last chose for
you yes same file due respect to all you
great New Jersey state for [ __ ] happens
I have a buddy on to high school in
college with his brother was he was way
older than us he was price [ __ ] man he
was a senior when I was in seventh grade
he's kind of a wild cat and I saw my
friend years down the road and I'm like
dude what's up with you what happened
your brother he's a [ __ ] cop man like
that guys are cops like big-time cop man
killing I'm like wow you yeah but yeah
hold on there cuz it starts right yeah
he's like well hold on there um he got a
little bit of trouble my son what happen
he as well he know he would you keep
arresting like people who would have
these drug charge and stuff like that
and they found out he was constantly
[ __ ] the girls and like getting
[ __ ] like from all these like hall
girls or drug addicts and shot he'd pick
him up and maybe I don't please I'm on
parole he things like oh yeah suck my
dick and like he had multiple girls and
the one snitched on him
just got picked up by another cop she's
like no whatever officered always lets
me go I just suck his dick and he's like
what and she's like yeah I actually just
saw him the other day like this morning
and I took DNA from her genitalia okay
and that's how he got fired well you
know I always wonder how it would be as
a cop you're a young cop because women
and I I'll just tell you this story with
you there are people who are you know
they get caught and they may they can't
get a ticket or maybe they they're
they're on their third DUI or on their
whatever it would be catastrophic to
having today you know it when I go to
pull over yet Tiger Woods was sucked all
those chopsticks I know getting in
trouble I had dated a girl who said
basically kind of admitted she's I mean
you know as a girl I mean if the guy was
good-looking and you know but you know
it's he's got cuffs and he's got a gun
and and you know I mean if I had to like
[ __ ] him or suck his dick you know and
not get like a $500 ticket I mean or go
to jail then why what would be the big
deal her talking like that Julie
but I got very turned on he'd be the
hype on her with my dick these let's see
let's see next week you're driving down
the road you're a bunch of wine to drink
we get don't leaking pic companion [ __ ]
up in you've got a bunch of wine and
this big old police officer pulls over
and he's like down it just gonna kill
your career man I know you got Goldberg
stuff like that it's gonna be all over
give me a hand job with ya okay look at
me listen to me you [ __ ] I'm taking the
jail time I'm not doing that dude right
now Randy I'm not doing it with a handle
the opposite if it's a girl no no no no
no no that's too easy if it's like oh no
it's the cop he's like he looks like
[ __ ] uh
you know he looks like the dad from from
a Fresh Prince of Bel Air
making me mad right now listen to me so
dad's from fresh bread yeah fellas okay
he pulls you over he's like
coughs want you to know man they're
dying to get your head shot out of here
and can be all over the news what have I
done that went by there honey call your
agent
dude if you actually give to I you
didn't fight from the Goldbergs
talk to Brendan's right no more fighting
the kid we came in to stand your ace
mistake something came to stand up
you're right let's take something up
stakes high and that guy goes I heard
with your friends your agent said on the
phone listen we forget all about this
just jack off the piece here ok take you
hold on I got something wish this year
old kettlebell mile trained officer I
got some questions how can I do for you
no real it I'm gonna do this but I don't
want to look you in the eye it'll help
you ok and also when you do shoot I want
to make sure that doesn't come come in
it where do I aim it don't don't see
shoot don't shoot them cop
ok so be reported ok so let's say so
you're older I'll if you're older so I
know it dribbles it doesn't shoot that's
all I'm saying it probably tastes a
little big right now I'm onto your money
shot I shoot ropes ok well if you're
gonna shoot ropes bro we're we have a
problem is we're talking about a
hazardous waste here say yeah you're
right you're rolling the gun here ok so
I'm going I got already able to go
that's all I need to know because you're
going to be wiped and sustained out that
blue uniform oh you can't have that ok
is that if this touches if a drop
touches me um you're giving me a handy
dime I'm taking it I'm booking you what
am I supposed to up and what I doing
what I don't get cleared oh you're in
trouble for yours if you go I'll
Emilia's all right hang tight okay then
just whatever your clothes and that's
what I'm gonna do and he's not going to
know it drop can't touch all right the
minute that [ __ ] about to bust
I'm taking a giant wad I'm taking a guy
I'm taking one of the towels one of
those little hand towels I keep in my
trunk and the minutes and I'm gonna I'm
gonna I'm gonna muzzle that bad boy just
the way I do endless pleasures exactly
why i kidnap somebody if i was pulling
them into my van you know how they did
with Corey I'm gonna [ __ ] chloroform
the enemy your dick I'm gonna go huh I'm
gonna muscle that [ __ ] I'm gonna
[ __ ] you're gonna come right into my
[ __ ] into that towel I'm gonna I'm
gonna muck dancing I'm gonna hold it
down there you go then I'm gonna wipe
mop and I take that rag I'm gonna burn
that I'm wearing know you found other
services I'm gonna turn on by the side
of my cry I'm gonna wash my hand watch
the skin off my hand that's fair that's
how it is well that's all it takes
if you want to muzzle my dick why bus
climbing's you know I'm gonna mouth the
back your Tecla why your friend I'm
small tells you to Teslas well exactly
what were that reason in case I'm
Hofstra law hey now hey you had a long
that you guys you've thought about it
give and you'll a silence my plug didn't
yeah you want to silence with me you
know throw muzzle on top here's my
question here is a woman she's a cop now
she's a big girl
look define big give it give me a
celebrity that she look like she's not
that in the probably open she probably
played d1 basketball Paul she's got
she's and she's got a set of shoulders
on her okay she's got big hands she's
got a strong jaw but she's a woman she's
just a guide and a she's like good cop
was the face I'm just gonna say she's me
she was a 50 was 11 her face though
she's pushing 15 and she looks a little
bit like Demi Moore Bryan Callen with a
wig okay now listen to me
Demi Moore Brice don't know that's
anymore very hot you know how that Demi
Moore tonight hey hey bro shut the [ __ ]
up while I was your favorite
yeah this is my fantasy alright she's a
big white 50 year old the black cop yeah
who played a lot of ball who is not
afraid of Pop Tart she eat some food
she's got some extra weight on she's no
[ __ ] type of lady she's just a no
[ __ ] I get pulled over all punch she
can throw a spiral now she's a good cop
what are you pull over for them okay
well you got post and a speeding ticket
you ain't seen my dish you got pulled
over and I'll tell you what you were
drinking and a guy when he's [ __ ]
headed here's my gift to you and he
drops a an eight ball of cocaine maybe
even more
and he goes knock yourself out you're
like I've never done cocaine cuz I know
you haven't he's like hey there's always
a first this [ __ ] is pure and I'm gonna
tell now to get rid out she sees that
and goes I'm I'm gonna send you to jail
you're going a good a prison this is
cocaine distribution to distribution
soon but let me show you what he's
[ __ ] line yeah you doing four to six
i watch your president shows on message
or I'm gonna pull this belt off and I'm
going to open the legs and you got a you
got to go to town until I buck
come Wednesday go to town you're all
Duggar with my suit please no no no you
need it you need to get down there with
you Tom Dubrow
don't be a [ __ ] don't be a baby cuz I
would do it in a heartbeat out here [ __ ]
I don't have to tolerate you do it you'd
rather do that than [ __ ] muzzled big
Carlton or big Fresh Prince of Bel Air's
dad's dick uh yes I would yes I [ __ ]
would yeah Hey look at me yeah I would
dude wouldn't you or you saying you'd
rather jack off Johnny Johnny big piece
with your bare hand and muzzled his his
his trt load as it as it bus I guess
you'd rather catch come and I'd rather
I'd rather go down on a woman yeah so
yeah that's the answer to me so we just
created a very important line in the
sand here ladies and gentlemen see
things you know where I stand and I
think you know with a big man with these
ridiculous loafers he paid way too much
money for our because he's wearing Gucci
loafers with a tiger on him I'm you know
what sometimes I just want to walk away
it's good I did you also do I want mean
Krista to get up top we're gonna rent
the cop car and pull you over and make
you muzzle eyes dick dude Chris laughs
is my goal in life Chris Lee is making
me laugh so hard we're eating at late
night at swingers and and Michael anoche
who's my boys very funny guy but Mike is
a regular guy Mike is in the guy in the
movie who's just the sidekick and then
he's got his other buddy and another
buddy and they're their regular looking
white guys they couldn't be more regular
looking white guys t-shirts you know
jeans will do them yep they shop in
white cupcake shop and they shop it the
gap there were you look like you'd find
them in mile high comics yep just this
white guy generic white cell at my hotel
and rent and and that really is like hey
sidekicks he's called him sidekicks his
psychic stopped talking anyway psychics
listen to me or a psychic get up or then
he's gone a guy guy who would be in a
movie and have three lines for the rest
of his life uh he was hit that with
those guys I stood when his girls around
I think they broke up
I was out to dinner with him there's a
table small it was crowded his
girlfriend shows up he licks his fingers
get up if I could get up you guys like
what eating you get up just gets up so
get it out my groaning so in cities like
all your algo women love Chris D'Elia
who doesn't mean a [ __ ] because they
want to have a day all when I have sex
with them they all look at him but you
have that I mean women like you but
something about Chris that long hair and
that wispy tofu body of his was also
hilarious he's hilarious but that
doesn't it was gain he's also famous
Laura that yeah also same a TOEFL that
helps [ __ ] I met your boy and hired
I'm like I finally the guy you're always
plugging on the shoulder so yeah of
Toronto good guy great guy connect with
him when I'm in Toronto we have a mutual
friend and Matty Matheson from travel
yeah yeah we got from the vice show the
chef oh yeah mm-hmm
yeah it was great I'll see him when I'm
in Toronto this is one of those kids
yeah good dude really good dude really
good dude he's took me a funny story how
he's I cotton I had no idea I no clue
but did so ex-girlfriend of his he's
like dude you know I don't know he is
pissing me off like we're kind of about
to break up I don't through it and I got
on Instagram she's liking on your
pictures and putting comments and all
this stuff
oh my god I don't yeah he called me
about a lifetime ago Japanese bread and
talking her I go no he's not talking
already got a girl I promise yeah I said
you I go hey I don't know you ever heard
yeah you mean a girl's liking my
pictures yeah I told that all you want
to do I told her the good I've nothing
to do what I couldn't tell I have no
idea I guess she was like putting the
sushi emoji on your pictures like I
again I don't I don't know what to tell
ya
was she hot though do you ever number
she was she was 12 he was a good lookin
dude yes I'm sure he dated nothing but
soft yeah he runs a successful gym he's
got two two huge martial art MMA as well
as you tell me funny stories with some
good times yeah good guy Tom well it's
our time I'll see that's our time is
jamming so
[Music]
so how weird is it the difference
between a commie store crowd and the
Improv crowd big big difference
completely different I don't know why
either it's interesting because that
comedy star crowd is amazing when they
pack that main room it's I mean sold out
every [ __ ] night my favorite place on
earth
yeah really but I feel like I feel the
Comedy Store is tougher than anywhere in
the world it is I think so because you
got like thing but just last night you
had you daliyah Rogen yeah BRR you're
gonna see the best comics in the world
mark man yeah you did yeah Lee Wallace
he humps a girl this is about a comics
in the world at the comic store every
single stuff I feel like the bar there
is the best play the bar there is so
high to this and the crowd is like okay
yeah we just saw Julia you're up yeah
and we thought you had to follow Thalia
Thalia in a different but I'm just
saying I'd like people is like I
improper laughs I could like man if you
if you can get some laughs of the comedy
store yes you can go anywhere 100%
anywhere we always used to say that and
especially the original room you are is
really dark and then it's just there's
something about the lighting that Mitzi
shore kind of did on purpose apparently
like the lighting is it's so dark and
dreary and the Comedy Store you know
when I used to do the Comedy Store every
night it was never like it is today
never it was empty
well it was just you know you never knew
it'd be like 12 alcoholics in a room
you'd do a spot at 1:00 a.m. it was
really crazy that doesn't exist anymore
now it's just there are lines they turn
people away with the improv sold out
left side - yeah it's good time to come
we did it it really is a good time for
comedy there's a lot of great comedy out
there and it's the best way to spend
your money as a hashtag quality but has
no comedy zone
July 20th 21st 22nd and Charlotte North
Carolina where I'll be hashtag if you
want to laughs it's the best place to
spend your money though you're 20 20
bucks or 25 bucks and you're gonna laugh
harder than any movie you've ever been
in look with it's $20 in you're seeing
again your silly a Bryan Callen bill
burr yeah Joe Rogan Marc Maron's you're
seeing you're seeing yes yeah easy it is
an amazing night you know it's a good
night when other comics are watching
mm-hmm
you know what I'm saying mm-hmm you were
killing me you had a good bed last night
I already told you plenty good very good
have you changed the prices much icon I
don't know I don't know what was it well
in the forties be what's happened not
like what were the prices in the 40s
when you doing it
talk don't be don't be a jean you know
Coco killer [ __ ] say stuff like that
all right
no but what was it like in the 90s or
2000s it was who died was way more there
would it would be it was the price for a
no oh I don't know what to prime you can
you google Chu in a pile then I would
said where people were allowed in and
they would pay for the room probably at
that and they would just make their
money on booze I think that's what a lot
of what no papers no answer you know
what's crazy to me is with the little
experience I have on toward [ __ ]
Manchester and my so check us out
Manchester the theater Manchester I do
one show there and then we had six shows
in Dublin we just now to shoot this last
night the small Aldabra album sold 6,000
of them sold oh yeah
anyways this is what so you're going to
be there for six nights or are you going
to do turn it to a night not a bunch of
in a day yeah I'm at Nate morning 9
[ __ ] British it shows I don't know
it's pretty I'll take it but what's
fascinating to me is you know I don't
think a lot of people know this is if
you do like a calmly store like a club
you make as an artist you make a lot
more money than if you do a theater can
get overhead yes like when you book a
seeder
right and there might be 4,000 3,000
people yes
you almost make the exact same if you do
a small club multiple shows yeah it
depends but yes because sometimes
theater there's no there's no minimum
drink required you're doing 3,000
skaters you're making money but if
you're doing all I'm not your lover I'm
a 1200 seater you're not making as much
spent oh yeah because you think
promoters are paying off yeah you say
and you I pay the promoter
you okay all do you guys cover the cost
to overhead yes employees there's no to
drink minimum
yep bring up Jim Carrey there I want to
see what I'm let's look at how much it
was there there's no way for me to find
it put where I can find
but can we carry this gun yeah let's
watch him for two seconds
my name is younger that's Jim Carrey
Rogen put it on my name is Jim Carrey
I'm a singing comic impressionist and
I'd like to start off this evening with
a piece from the new punk ballet wounded
Swan Lake
that's in the lower-right yeah sure is
no I think I spent practically my entire
life staring in the mirror I have I
wasn't staring at me I was staring at
Leonid Brezhnev you know he was he was
he stopped doing this stuff but I don't
know why I stopped doing stand-up I've
never understood why guys who become
really famous stopped doing stand-up a
little solvent like they go to get into
movies and then they put out but
everything I don't know they were gentle
yeah I keep doing stand-up I could never
build clouds to understand there's all
shows get him they did you know even
while he's going through like the trial
and everything also performing he's
trying to I'm gonna propose like I feel
like it's a bad idea
yeah I would imagine right they pass on
that I would imagine maybe pass but he
could just rent out a theater he's got
something like 60 lawsuits coming his
way though yeah it's not good not good
at all mo mandel um other Billy one
that's long for more grace than Bill
Cosby OJ Simpson yeah dysentery good
yeah okay to integral cut their heads
off practically yeah Oh Jay Simpson and
we're okay was so well soaked loudly
talking about America's dad I think Bill
Cosby is even bigger
I really do he was acted more than
American in a negative way not I was the
America's daddy was the first
entertainer I believe to make a billion
dollars wasn't he and he was such a he
was such like and talk about a guy who
was still doing incredible stand-up up
into his 70s
ya know Jay Simpson he was kind of you
know he was both he was beloved by
everyone he's a football player Heisman
Trophy winner won the best possible
players all-time great Pro player then
crossed over to pop culture cousin you
know make it done in the half and all
that stuff doing all those endorsement
deals
yeah doing some work for like CBS
football yes I say Bill Cosby's bigger
deal
um bill class is more famous yeah I
don't know ok Simpson was famous but
bill cosby's world famous that's not
saying yeah The Cosby Show was so big it
was so big yeah yeah I would agree I
think that's the biggest fall from grace
also like this is gonna sound great
ladies rule everything you've ever done
is ruined but check this out like you
and I and all of us can go OK he killed
a man and his wife LJ all of us as
people can can do this they can go a
terrible crime but I can see in your
darkest moment it's your girl she's with
another guy and you have a fit of rage
and you Kelsey is all this time we have
so many stories of a crime of passion
comes in my you bother Tina oh my god I
killed we can understand temporary rage
that would lend itself to murder as
actually fighting that I can't
understand killing my girl that's
explaining I can under it before yes I
see what you said before also but you
can also understand that I had a
momentary lapse of madness that caused
murder like we all have even courses but
he of course recognized that the courts
recognize something called a crime of
passion true and people gotten off on a
crime of passion like you were not in
your right mind you were so jealous of
you I caught a man in bed with my wife
and I shot them both and so but this is
different because this is a guy who was
like planning out whether to rape
somebody by getting them drugged and
then raped over how many years over yeah
I did it too how many women nah sixty I
don't know what it was so this was
obviously this compulsion and this and
it's crazy to think about this was this
this example you know this this wasn't
me and by the way don't copy me would
really easily know but this is what he
was editor to my level
did you it semi-wet you probably only
way get off that one whatever that's
what that a thing things Jamie sharper
is that safety for the New Orleans
Saints captain the team played for the
Packers do captain team dimepiece thanks
Bill Cosby look like a straight piece of
cat [ __ ] in the Sun like yeah James
sharper died
peace and he said you know he's in
prison I think for 15 years now I'm in
prison I think 15 years
Jamie sharper Jamie sharper look you up
but he was saying uh yo J you just came
too easy to me so then the challenge was
is using these date rape drugs
I tried outsmart him because his
teammates like like tough Jamie well
he's more girls than anyone on the team
he's like it just got too easy
my obsession became you know that I know
yeah but you just can't do that [ __ ]
he's willing to clearly can't do it but
for ghosting that stuff honestly damn
what out what a career in the NFL to
that is that the right guy Darren
Sharper Darren share and sharper any
sorry Jamie sharper look at him that's a
good-looking guy what oh I think we
looked at this guy before - yeah look at
that [ __ ] dude man and he got a sick
thing [ __ ] College but I scroll out
I started gets eighty so eighteen years
twenty years
twisted the crimes of former NFL hair
serial rapist click on that for me yeah
he goes into a house he like you got so
many chicks I would have a super famous
guy everyone here would known he's a
beast on the guitar he got so many girls
the hot one in the world year after year
he's like I'm just gonna try start
[ __ ] dudes there's no mystery left
with women who a guy I can't mention but
see that that to me is a guy who's
always been gay I don't know and I don't
know if he was having sex so Jamie
sharper got 18 years in prison for
drugging at least nine women across four
states in order to rape them damn and
nine think how many Cosby did also don't
you and I don't let jr. stood like that
kind of guy don't you know you're gonna
get caught - don't you know that there's
a bills are gonna get away with that
[ __ ] do I that just depresses me anyway
um no but to meet like I built Ozzie
he's famous it but he looks like pure
[ __ ] let's be real like it's not gonna
be a model
Jamie sharper freak athlete God and look
Easter tell his friends she's on the
potion
she's ready damn yeah man I think these
are weird things where people have these
strange fetish fetishes you know these
crazy
or maybe it's a feeling of power or your
your your your getting over on somebody
or something you're taking something
that doesn't belong to to hit this one's
close to home sharper sharper met two
women on January 14th seven fourteen
that Bootsy bellows nightclub on Sunset
Strip in LA been there multiple times
good thing I didn't take the drink yeah
after they attended the Roosevelt Hotel
Bar 50th for Sports Illustrated then
they made plans to go to another club
Sharper offered the women a ride first
cremates began with a man they blacked
out
they made me nauseous every shots the
drinks tastes odd within ten minutes
that blacked out next one one felt the
job a little bit god damn know what why
are you trying to have sex with somebody
who's passed out Mike but if the girls
are with you why do you got to fixing
these drinks well not just because I'll
say like that's crazy in fact it's
[ __ ] craziness that people do this
insane like behavior this oh my god I
know I had a girlfriend where this
happened to her and she went well anyway
I don't want to talk about him Tolstoy
but this kind of stuff happens dude
story with bad people good call dude she
fell and hit her head and her girlfriend
found her in the bathroom and so nothing
happened but she the guy gave her the
drug and she went to the bathroom she
didn't feel right at all and she's like
oh no I've been drugged
boom fell smack he's gotta go ran in and
found her and the guy who did it was a
cop like yeah so she was really afraid
fishy when she told me she brought me in
and she looked around that's still going
on all the time this is not a very good
said I didn't rape this even though they
had people walking around no [ __ ] right
I mean that's what I'm saying when you
say with no no no no listen I'm saying
because there's a huge issue with date
rape drugs like it was big in college I
meant oh my god in college you tell
girls do not take a drink for many guys
don't do any of that stuff make sure you
go to the bar yourself get your drinks
you know what I
Jilla betting that dude never in came
across hearing about it in my world at
least you're a little older so I think
you missed that bone I know if I know
that memo even where that happened like
and I don't know we all know so and I'm
just saying it was like a real issue I
wonder if it's still going on are people
more keen to announce it it's not as
high here's my thing like you and I like
so so if we had a friend who came up to
us and said hey no wonder God is an
island drug the I'd be like if you put
that integrals over on doin they don't
they don't do that they do it on their
own I just see they know cuz they're
sick in the head they're making like a
bro I'm look great having Darren Sharper
was he was like she's ready I got the
potion gone he mentioned to the staff or
severed you know to them like potion
like maybe that's alcohol he's not
saying hey I put [ __ ] roofies in a
drink they're ready to go he's going
what do they have to pay [ __ ] I don't
know what it is we didn't get it with
your pharmacist RGH what I need Robby's
RHP a ton of GHB
oh maybe why I know I have no idea I
might add GHB one time potentiate GI put
GHB under my tongue I was in a hot tub
la Granja Grosso was there I was at this
fancy guy's house in Denver at time I
single there's Lobby he was like yeah I
was after be coke up wasn't see him not
with the girly much who cares but um
this doctor throws this huge party for
me this she time he has the most amazing
answer saying we're in his hot tub and
there's GHB on you know I'm not a drug
guy you know do this you feel great if
he's a doctor he fried egg all right
guys Yeah right well she got to
prescribe my goddamn everyone else do it
I'm gonna do it but my brother me my boy
Cody two other dudes all dudes and the
thought then we take it down feel pretty
good first of all I already worried why
is not my day of my bogus I know I'm
like [ __ ] all the chicks Oh what's up
becoming is out of be here be here like
yeah but it's really like a lengthen no
so you know I don't like oh boy and then
half an hour goes by having some drinks
doing a little more there's food
you know we eaten in the hot tub like
drop in [ __ ] nachos in the hot tub
whatever I like I'm gonna [ __ ] as the
girls in his and he's probably doing
some other stuff you
girls don't show up man you are your
softness for zelos stuff [ __ ] does that
mean it's a bull you didn't play that
[ __ ]
right hey you're trying to get us all
little softened up huh hopefully make
them so we make some whoopsie decisions
whoops so funny look hey Doc what's your
dick doing there don't feel I didn't
feel much officer you think I'm so bad a
doctor then yes oh they ran a train on
me because I had the GHB made it easy
yeah so you uh yeah it probably didn't
work as well on you because you're so
big and I was like I don't feel that
much different people acting real gay up
in here bro girls on show Hey look at me
of each other ha Jigga's [ __ ] this
double water
man anybody was gonna die mom scratch my
dick it's super-hard estrangement we
didn't look like wrestling you know did
some light wrestling yeah if you lube up
and do some light round no I thought
that guys I like ripped his toenail off
oh no you did so you actually did
wrestle did anybody's [ __ ] fly out of a
speedo
no beer and swim trunks rustling what I
working really yeah and he was like I
wrestled in high school like very cool
man and I got [ __ ] around with Jay
and compost it I [ __ ] around with Jay
like you know mess around we do rather
on brevin he was like I wrestled I was
going very cool man and I still try and
play with my friends he's like you
should in I just remember like let's see
how it goes and this is right after beat
croak out sighs I had no surgery too so
I can't really get physical
yeah and he came at me I remember I got
another hooking just like flip them in
the end is his foot hit like this life
above him Oh cut his toenail off so bad
like the entire big toenail oh my
like hey enjoy the GHB now cut right and
don't ever try sucking me again enjoy
that tongue yeah just blood if you are
yeah oh man good dude
you know that you know there's no scary
reason GHB is making a comeback 2016 but
they bring up John Stamos in here for
some reason uh when police stopped John
Stamos were swerving through Beverly
Hills in his silver Mercedes the most
surprising part of celebrities DUI
arrest was
that he was charged with driving under
the influence of date rape drug I've
talked to John the central nervous
system president is best known as
substance slipped in the drinks to aid
sexual assault preach yet Uncle Jesse
Uncle Jesse at the slap in his face yeah
Uncle Jesse was reportedly taking it on
purpose to lean out body house for
shooting a TV show uh I might be true
because John's not a gray he's not a
drug guy inside he doesn't drink either
GHB for lean body mass well that's what
they say so close to em GHB I can see
him doing that you know it's like a
little older than me now John's really
clean your aura of alcohol without the
sloppy side effect with slurred speech
like a party drew ow
I spent body Bo said increase productive
human growth hormone you have to take a
shitload of it don't sound asleep I
spent six weeks in John and spent a lot
of time in New York outside out who ever
saw him drink when users overdose
however Jeffrey can cause coma-like
sleep mix alcohol increases the
president effect googling on
consciousness see that's what that's
that Jamie sure and he just read it like
your idea you literally I go yeah I go
super fast I get it man yeah well I mean
we should get some in here it's all in
dose yelling ready for the pass out all
right just do so I've never done heroin
never done LSD never done here oh wait
till you hear how many people here win
yeah I know but what we in ordered it
just to try it once and every one of
them threw up yeah like why don't do
heroin it doesn't end well it's not an
experiencing necessarily as I watch way
too much intervention do any of those
drugs its persons like I was at a party
and a friend was like eight right here
and I've been addicted ever since if
it's that good it's constantly chasing
that dragon yeah it does it does make it
burn fat gives you it doesn't give you a
hang around makes you wanna have sex
that's pretty cool
I try it it's big in the gay community
or it was it's big in every community
yeah
GHB yeah don't just label gays not speak
for it yeah if you want yeah did you put
a rat sex on GHB maybe I have oh wait
and Jane have you that what I mean who
knows looks like you'd do some decent
damage
cocaine table yeah like so you go
straight up I've only done like legal
natural stuff okay demand Oh when Aubrey
was here uh the chin uh abri I had a few
questions and things like what do you
think of insert name in all these drugs
was like whoa whoa whoa what what do
which ones have you done chin so that
what I was talking about was kratom you
know kratom have you heard about kratom
crayon sure haven't
it's like a dried leaf plant from
Indonesia and it's it's legal here and
it's it's very pain and it makes you
feel like you're taking coffee but more
relaxed it's like a looks like a decaf
coffee oh my god here's my thing about
all these drugs well conflation happen
like go in pity somebody gives me a pill
sony says I got some X for you I guess I
don't I don't know where that pill came
from and I don't know what's in that
pill and I don't know who made it in a
lab so I ain't taking it yeah I know
you're a hot girl who spends her money
dancing but and you get good drugs but I
don't know about this particular policy
sure tighten up nope hey chin so all
you've done is that those plants um as
of late oh you know I'm saying I'm
saying like ever ever some please be a
single room used to be a Korean say for
those guys those k-pop stars [ __ ] those
k-pop stars gbuv enough ah ah hey they
get surgeries okay what a hottest yet
announcer you're not I'm just saying
that they're known for it though how
about my wife I'm with Jen my wife
Chin's very handsome I love your wife
she's on haulin handsome air to try to
plug Stephen eh eh no she just said that
he was very handsome tall and handsome
now mr. Calzada flashin hey listen I
don't know what he's I can't read a
woman's mind
well she like was alarmed out it's not
it by the way might might the guy who
trained my dogs Nathan who's got his own
show on Animal Planet
you marine for nine years it couldn't be
better looking couldn't be better
looking my wife all bright-eyed and
[ __ ] bushy tails and her friends want
to come over and get you know and didn't
buy a dogs it's ridiculous you're trying
to [ __ ] I'm like
I'm like hey I know he's 35 and couldn't
be better looking but can you take it
easy in front of me I'm your [ __ ]
husband she's all blushy and asking him
questions I'm like you [ __ ] kidding
me right now I'm out now man a ton of
suction they went home you're avoiding
what words going on here oh I want no
Qin's drug history all right
yeah that are Oh what else like he's not
gonna answer dude okay is right ecstasy
before ooh
weird never tried ecstasy I'll answer
the question yes I'll say yeah I've
tried actually before and then it was
normally like the happiest I've ever
felt
yeah from anything so were you with
girls or is like you with a whole group
of people yeah yeah I did it in San
Francisco when I was young man I
couldn't believe how cool I was I
couldn't believe I'm how do I was we
mean how cool you were like how cool
hotel dance and I was like well I'm the
best dancer in the world and I'm in the
best place in the world and everything's
amazing and my girlfriend and I we were
talking about were each other's mates we
loved each other we're maybe chuckling
mates and then at the end of the night
the end of the night overdub it started
to wear off and I had to I had to cross
a felt rope there was a rope that was on
the ground and I just had to step over
the rope and I I was like I can't do
this little I couldn't and I gotta go
sir please step over sir please step
over sir please step over and I I was
managed to look at my girl and I went
ahhh I reached my hand and super [ __ ]
up I I don't know what happened and she
grabbed my hand and she pulled me over
and I got out of it and then I then we
had sex and it was the best sex of all
time I've Miller then I could say be
like I and then I got a cold n I got
sick first
but you're dope it like it over saturate
your dopamine sensors right so you're
super depressed like the next three days
I got crap for that thing I felt like
crap I didn't feel like I didn't tell
the press back Tyler press we feel like
crap because it really so many yeah I
felt pretty sad it was amazed you know
people say to take that the new mood
like Sabri about I wish people who do
that you take 5-htp new mood and eque
take a shitload of it and it kind of
skips that kind of hassle I guess again
I'm not a big drug debt of the the most
issues I've ever had is I ate a friend
of mine whose balls deep in
a weed and edibles and at the time I
wasn't at all gave me a super strong
like four times strong strength brownie
is a fattest brownie
look you got huge mind on that huge and
she's like out he told me your sizes
it's really like an effect you need the
whole thing and I ate the whole thing
and then like two three hours later I
mean I could I could barely move
now you can worse experience you can't
feel you could be you can't breathe I
feel like you're hard I see I didn't
panic I just like I couldn't move I
could not like I was at home I focus I
was home salsa I just was trying to eat
oranges as apples like I was just dying
yeah I've been that high on a brownie I
ate half a brownie I've never been that
edible so the worst night because it
just last forever and ever and also you
don't know how long you say you can't
die on edibles you cannot die off any
marijuana is that right it's impossible
to die Wow well you just pass out or you
can also Wow cannot dies cannot you know
there's nothing that's good to know
because I thought I was going to die I
was really well oh yeah some people get
super panicked yeah you panicked I don't
do well you talked to Aubree don't hook
la cute like what you after he's talking
about all those kind of natural drugs
and how it helps with PTSD and the other
psychedelic you're not a nervous person
I am a nervous person me you're not a
nervous person like you don't worry
you're not a hypochondriac that stuff no
yeah why would I be I am you are Brian
yeah I'll take you that I'm not really
but I you are you are bad I will be
sometimes like if I have no you are for
sure I know you well enough where you're
like your mom is alright yeah it sounds
for yes yes yes just like I imagined the
worst case scenario sometimes oh you're
not a nervous person no I don't think
I'm a nervous person I'm too happy to be
married you know but you get like a bump
or you like my stomach hurts I yes yes I
wrong my body I'm proud to [ __ ] like my
back's been itching I'm like cancer
again you know that kind of stuff no not
at all it has to be like see your [ __ ]
for me girl again so yeah like this my
friends like that my friend will have
crazy [ __ ] going on and she's like man
[ __ ] I'm like we'll go to the doctor
and go I do it usually yeah where the
[ __ ] is you Invisalign just don't worry
but I forgot it at home people Rosi
juice
so bad on your teeth that video you
posted um I saw oh my god did they roast
me oh that's how I guess not I can't get
it yes so I know I'm rule is so annoying
well you guys I have the last laugh when
I have straight teeth and sick you gotta
have straight teeth
I've been a little remiss with children
you know Joe's mom's a dental assistant
like you don't wear enough you might as
well not do it
I'm cuz she goes I never see him with a
monitor where she watches the show yeah
you know I can't wear them when I'm
talking but you're always talking I
really got them no I'm wearing a 50 I
wear them dude Rach just the city's guys
know I love what I do and I'm wearing
them and I'm gonna fix my teeth get out
of my mouth I was with you all day
yesterday all last night you didn't have
one what that's fair I can't perform
with with Invisalign so you do a
20-minute set and show them the rest of
the day then I got to talk to everybody
like head out how are you and I knew
you're right I should be wearing them
I'm not just always high no it's not I'm
gonna commit to it and you're not I'm
gonna wear them all right bro I feel you
just need where the bottom ones no you
gotta wear both because you have your
mouth has to mine I don't want to talk
about it anymore
at least all the light heads cleared up
monkey face I don't have white head to
the my came back in from New York you
know I was like God dog yep you guys are
splinter head my wife was laughing so
hard about peyote she was like I was
like don't laugh at my expense that's
what they say when you said you stuck
your head out of the subway let's do
some good or an offense with Brendan and
Brian on chin too in love drugs
so cheering Oh cheering Kim love drugs
game she loves drugs
oh okay the first one is a South
Carolina soccer like a youth team
they're not allowed to have their
parents cheering the exes parents get in
fight yelling yeah I lived through their
children because they lose lost you I
saw this on Good Morning America this
morning where parents are allowed to
cheer and other leagues are adopting the
same things because sometimes make the
kids feel bad and if your kid does
something good just stay silent [ __ ] you
my kid will not be in any part of those
you know not tell me how to
on to my kid you know why they're saying
that though cause parents are getting in
fights and they're actually worried more
about the parents yelling at the
referees the referees are kids
apparently they're like 14 15 or 16 I
don't have 15 year-olds as referees
though yeah also they there are fights
in the stands it gets crazier that's the
exception though kind of I grew up
around this culture not really you not
really right no it's the culture we live
in the anything exception like this puts
a fight America where no you hurting the
kids feelings and you don't yell at the
rest of those are literally that is part
of the game but away that's the cold
it's also part of life there are winners
and losers
you [ __ ] egalitarians who is
controlling this [ __ ] is that the
Illuminati the new Illuminati the speech
police and these [ __ ] people that
enforce this weird egalitarian world
know the world has winners and losers
you're rather good enough or you're not
and if you're not good enough you're
supposed to try to get better so do you
beat the guy that you lost to before
it's not what the American Way or life
is about you read this all parents a
loser shall be silent during the game no
cheering I would find this no cheering
no jeering just enjoy your player in the
game that they love I'd be fighting this
I would be here and I'm elves and
whistles throw these pings I would I
wait to my event of a place to like you
violate the rule in the first instance
during a game the referee will ask the
coach to counselors parent to remain
silent
[ __ ] it's crazy game that's your
doing the kids a disservice you're not
helping anyone you the kids are they're
not getting a real a real experience on
how sports work they're gonna get to
high school like oh my god people cheer
and boo they're going to make the
parents laptop said team boo here's how
about gue here's how they [ __ ] each
team manager so obtained parents
signatures on behalf of each player on
their roster acknowledging their
awareness of the parent visitor code of
conduct so in other words what are you
saying I can't speak I can't I can't say
good job to my kid
hey where's it at South Carolina South
Carolina but yeah there are people that
push the [ __ ] through it's not just all
rich whites
well it's somebody else yo third world
small group of [ __ ] who are pushing
this through then [ __ ] them they're dumb
- this is how they solve a problem
leathered is actually they're [ __ ]
their kids up no those kids
amount to [ __ ] in sports what else you
get you next one is ice cube I know the
story so Ice Cube said that for the big
three basketball game that was supposed
to go on the same day as a McGregor
fight he said that they're willing to Co
promote with what the fight promoters
how about you throw away listen I like
ice cube as an artist I like all that
how about you ZigBee things kind of
disappear cuz it's pure [ __ ] well I hate
saying that cuz our boy Michael rap for
works with it but it's ridiculous wait
and you explain what I I missed that
part what do you know you know how the
big three basketball thing that Ice Cube
does it was supposed to be for the
t-mobile Arena the same day which is
anybody if I were talking you did
tweeted about I was into these round 3
no I delete it it's about that same
league though it's okay
so they actually booked the venue before
the August 26 thing with McGregor and
Mayweather so then now they're trying to
like kind of get themselves involved
into that fight as well so they're
saying that uh they would be super happy
to co promote with with the five
promoters in this event and then there's
another funny thing they said here so
the CEO of big three said that the five
promoters have indicated to us that they
are very they're every bit as thrilled
to work with us as we are with them I
can't which is not our delicious go away
I find that very hard to believe
and now yesterday and Showtime is not
doing that and then today this came out
that Ice Cube said he's willing to move
for the mayweather fight
how are the ratings of the big three you
got about old outdated basketball
players playing three-on-three
basketball what has the world come to go
to the YMCA gota [ __ ] in the park up
the street watch three on three what the
[ __ ] is going on man it's funny sex I
love watching tennis and I was watching
the legends play like John Mackey I was
like sixty now with another guy and it
just it ain't that interesting
not just ISM you know I go three on
three basketball
I mean it's so stupid well he's gonna
make a ton of money on this yeah oh my
god there's compare of a few million
like take your three on three do in the
parking lot
no one cares don't do it in the ratings
been abysmal I mean I had nothing on Fox
Sports 1
it's good I mean I've never seen it
before have you I've seen anything about
it you'll be it's just a bad idea
well she gets you you guys were talking
about DWIs duis this guy has his fifth
DWI and he's getting a life sentence in
jail for it I get that can I tell you
what happened three yeah I get it
because he like he's that very very he's
getting into two tons of fast-moving
steel and driving and you're gonna kill
somebody eventually and I'd rather him
go to jail for life than somebody some
kid died yeah you're absolutely right
because this guy's perhaps she's
obviously rehabs not working they've
probably done he's been through the
system how many times look at this
you're gonna kill somebody
previously convicted of two misdemeanor
counts in 87 then sentenced to three
years two for two felony counts in 89
and then in 94 years in prison for
felony DWI and then in 95 three years in
prison and then he was serving a 15-year
prison sentence for this and was on
parole and then he got this so hold he
has to go he's a more yeah he just can't
know any other I'm not sure he wants to
get caught
yeah but with uber this day and age who
cries yeah that's true maybe maybe a
water he rugs to keep him off like but
if he's not gonna take the drugs I just
can't right it's too dangerous
maybe he loves drinking and drive and
you ever think about that maybe that's
what he wants to do you know what that's
that's legit because he seems to do it
and pay a big price and he also might
like the system there's some guys that
don't like the real well he likes the
system he's like [ __ ] I like drinking
driving I like the system if I get
caught whatever Vega I agree you're
getting what you want in that situation
right looks like your death yeah I think
I'm going Oh check this up this is like
a it's going viral right now it's this
fish the tuna cut in half yeah and it's
continuing to move I've seen it before
when fish move but this is completely
holy [ __ ] that's just a virus firing
yeah it's all the nurses oh I would chop
that up and put it on a [ __ ] crunchy
rice roll amazing still moving yeah it's
moving hardcore too it's jumping out of
its range
that's fresh fish right the other piece
is moving to
and then that is some fresh so they
didn't hit me
that's incredible associate Grange don't
they say chickens and get the head off
still come around hey Ron yeah so
there's that people - yeah I heard the
people heads up you'd have death well a
brain can live without oxygen for you
know and so apparently when with the
guillotine when somebody's head would
come off people would be mouthing
prayers like you'd see them still right
yeah yeah because the brain the blood
doesn't rush out yeah I mean the heart
that the day in the wolf in this old
movie it was always like the idea was
you technically when you got your head
cut off could be you could see your own
body without a head I was like the scary
part but it's not true I don't think I'd
imagine you're not conscious right when
you can do it who know don't know the
blood knowledge is still up there the
nerves still wrapped up their eyesight
still work she's not cutting off the
nerve and we gotta know all right but
they say the guillotine is a very
painless way to die
who did they talk to well I believe that
the guy who designed the guillotine was
a doctor dr. guillotine guillotine it's
French and I'm sure he's guilty more
like I don't know what infected the camp
I know it sounds barbaric but as far as
you know injecting people with these
chemicals and that can be a rough how
about I care about being electric
horrible yes the guillotine has it ever
not reel in swishes a sharp blade yeah
he was technology it's all blood I think
it's all about yeah but we don't you to
sound yet how many people see these
these executions where we inject these
Horrible's uh you know products into the
body rather go with guillotine believe
it or not hundred percent than being
electrocuted or being Ariat I was
watching this show they get you know me
and he's [ __ ] weird prison
documentaries so this guy so interesting
he's whatever 24 25 he went on a
high-speed chase right and they put down
those you know the tracks and like make
it stop and he's going going going and
then this cop went to go put down more
spikes a stop up and get away and
she didn't see the cop his cop kills him
but the cops who saw him go chase him go
no Pete he swerved riding that cop meant
to kill him so he's on trial for life he
gets life in prison for countertop but
through the trial they're trying to they
give him the death on this is taxes and
it takes to unplug ground so you know
how people appeal that all the time so
you know they might get it-- since the
death right but you can appeal it and
you should still around for 20 25 30 40
years you know the appeal process it
kills them right yeah homeboy goes no
kill me right now no excuse me has no
Appeals nothing I want dices fastest
basketball and they go why he goes
because I'm never getting out I don't
want to be in prison and I don't want my
family that it's taking a toll on their
yes he has kids his daughter there he's
interviewing with a Amy or the History
Channel they're interviewing gays up to
it like how you feeling and he's like
I'm just I'm excited to get it done like
I don't want to die he's like I don't
want to die but I know if I don't I'm
stuck in here I'm not appealing anything
like that so when people do this they
have to do a mental check to make sure
they're not crazy yeah he goes to that
like he's completely normal like he's a
rational thinker he's good to go the day
of like how he doing and he's like I'm
terrified
it's like heartbreak and he's like I'm
I'm terrified I was just never happened
and I don't want to die and his family
is like we wish he wasn't kill himself
like we'd want me to still see him him
visit and he's like if I'm in here
they're in here and I want them to move
on I want my girl my daughter to move on
and find the actual dad so when I die
and [ __ ] literally moments before the
interview he gets choked up and he takes
his mic off and goes like this like
thank you thank you for let me tell my
story boom goes out hours later Wow
nuts it's heart I heard a documentary
and never forgot on NPR and I can't
remember where was and they they were
talking about in South Africa during the
apartheid regime there were there was a
prison where if you are on death row
they would make you you would have to
build your own pine coffin and when they
would be
building their own pine coffin the other
inmates could hear it and the other
inmates would sing and they would sing
sort of these hymns to the person making
and the guy this one guy was was
hammering and hammering a beat as they
were singing and he was hit and they had
a recording of it and it was the most
[ __ ] incredible thing I'd ever heard
this guy was building his own coffin and
they were singing and I can't member the
documentary if anybody knows that I'm
hearing it on PR and I never was able to
seal into mr. Soze boy no it's not boy I
would you know I was like crying
oh these beautiful young African
prisoners were singing I was like [ __ ]
you guys in harmony like this and all
that there's some fascinating [ __ ] that
goes on with our judicial system and
it's crazy like there's there's one kid
who was like this weird like evil kid
saying should I forget what's called
super evil kid he convinced this other
kid that his childhood friend his dad
had a ton of cash in a safe like a ton
of cash and gold is we just got to get
in there and get the cash and then the
guy who doesn't know that his friend
goes what happens if your friends Dugas
we had to take care of them as well how
are you into that he goes you'll just
choke them out yeah like I remember this
jujitsu background where we just joke
around we keep going so they go in there
that evil kid sets up the whole plan he
gets like all this [ __ ]
bla bla bla they go in that kids
actually fights back they end up killing
him get the the kind of the muscle of it
took a knife and started stabbing like
20-something [ __ ] times they take the
money right they get picked up [ __ ]
like by my immediate look immediately
like there's chicken he picked up
immediately right but so this is this is
the best part you know how they dates
you don't stay together when they when
they go through the interrogation
there's separate rooms
but again the walls very thin so they
the cops that know this and they go
usually what hurt us this helped us
because they separate the two and the
guy goes right what happened and the kid
who was the mastermind behind it goes I
don't know man we go in and we're just
supposed to get the money and then next
no he [ __ ] kills my friend and it was
his idea and I tried to stop him I have
nothing to do it is like fakes cries
like my friend my friend and that
[ __ ] guy did it over homeboy who did
it
is all he goes like this on the wall
goes and the cop comes and goes hey quit
knock on the [ __ ] wall goes no I need
to talk to someone
his I will be in second it's 90 talk to
him right now oh yeah do you want to
talk to us yeah I do
he comes English I heard everything that
[ __ ] guy said this is what happens
breaks it down and goes I had no idea
she goes he's one that bought this he
did disco step through step through step
so that kid takes the kid who actually
did the killing who's the muscle gets
that he plead deals gets life in prison
the guy who actually didn't touch the
kid who came up with the plan gets the
death penalty
crazy man why he gets invested
definitely they're both [ __ ] [ __ ]
although both I'm thumbs put it so [ __ ]
those guys they're both [ __ ] more of
course hair cuz they know every frontal
cortex hasn't developed yeah I D it's so
clean young guys it's like my friends
you came to me when I was a young man
they're like we're gonna rob a jewelry
store I went yar they go yeah they were
all like kids from Jersey people say
that like you you're crazy in your old
Texas I never had that ever because you
could think ahead a little bit just a
tiny bit more no my friends II don't
know what I would think about J Shaw had
some issues but first of all I was never
going to do it but also shout to J
Shabbats birthday also I remember just
thinking myself I was like wait I'm a
young boy I'm a dude I'm dumb dumb I'm
gonna do something like this like you
know beat up some dude or you know mess
this guy up could you mess with my
friend do it in an organized way then
I'm going to be in an interrogation room
with with seasoned cops who are 50
who've been doing this for you know if
you live to interrogate your little yeah
man they you capable higher we're out of
those mother like this a great interview
I say I'm balls deep and Howard Stern at
emedicine that he is before the way
conducts interviews amazing we had Ice
Cube on and Ice Cube got picked up for
selling drugs
and but it was the Fed excuse us let me
tell you some if you get stopped by one
of these [ __ ] they start
questioning does
the questions they ask they already have
all the answers to you have no you
cannot live yours I think I do I feel
that they know every when they ask
they're not asking because they're
actually curious of your answer they
know the answer they're trying to just
make sure you're not [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah yeah that's right the way I see was
saying I was like good god oh yeah I
never had ever any friends like we
should kill him ever I'd like now what's
wrong with now
oh and I snitch on you real quick oh you
think that okay let me go tell my
janitor my dad in the cops I'm gonna go
I'm gonna tell the teacher right now hey
you know we were talking about how
teachers are [ __ ] of students we never
got hit on in high school or middle
school yeah some guys like shop enjoyed
this and it was a [ __ ] like mug shots
of all the hottest teachers that [ __ ]
this students and eat your heart out and
you look at you like what whoever sent
that to me shout to that random dude on
his game I was like what in the world
just smoke shows fantastic show
fantastic I love that sure what else you
got June all right I feel sick this lot
to have had four shots in it well God's
little sleep because we're out late last
night you and I both had two sets yeah
my Sun set and I couldn't get home to
1:00 a.m. my thing goes I had sets last
night that's fantastic well um Bubble
Guppies starts at 6:30 and I like to
wake up about 6:00 right and I love
bubblegum need some water so let's go
ahead wake your ass up at five hours
D : Bubba oh boy I know oh boy and then
he's just dancing that extra bubble
bubble bubble bubble you know kid him
that I didn't see that the important
text he sent before that about a
scheduling thing how ridiculous kids
it's like we good I didn't see the text
you butchered me and I was like auntie I
sent jail I literally it was like I
didn't see the text because I do put
your hint send me a very important text
about our schedule and then have your
son with that big mouth of his and face
I said just warning he to whatever
Bubble Guppies comes on he starts
dancing like trying to sing to it so I
filmed it with the volume aunt like so
my brother can see a volume I go look
he's singing happy birthday she goes
what really I went nice singing Bubble
Guppies but of course
Pawel Guffey's my son was obsessed with
Bubble Guppies big big show I say what
man [ __ ] me and they're doing it
right with like Pixar they do those
movies which for adults and kids because
when you have to fit through like Mickey
Mouse Club [ __ ] you Mickey Mouse Club
that is some amateur shared a Lego my
Center and really like it either
Bubble Guppies or Sponge Bob he's kind
of for spongebob but like Charlie Brown
any of the Pixar's the Megamind from
watching yeah because if it is not like
on to tears oh he'll get down with
family guy literally likes like the
clerk Toledo movies with with where will
arnett plays
hilarious they're all right to mimic to
cuz he does like kids on like Lego
movies really he's too Lou young my kids
yeah
arrived 9 my family guys are Cleveland
Show you know they have some weird
topics but family guys broke up a
brilliant I will laugh out Latta watch
like burst out laughing at some of the
[ __ ] it is hilarious American Dad it's
so funny American Dad he has body
dysmorphia and he has to pass this test
for whatever he's in the CIA you know
that's his his gay or through the
government American Dad
and yes surpasses physical tagging
animation thing yes his cartoons by Seth
MacFarlane are [ __ ] brilliant and he
has body dysmorphia anything he's really
fat but he can't see the way he looks
himself and he's actually anorexic it's
hilarious it's [ __ ] hilarious
damn the cartoon was so brilliant on so
amazing that if you go apparently I know
a girl him in his fifth grade class
there are cartoons I guess on the wall
where he was trying like him school yeah
you can sing his ass up you know album
out I now he's incredible he can sing
like Joe by Frank Sinatra look like Brit
I couldn't believe how yummy voices he
is on family or not all of them be
double joy like I didn't realize he was
that many he's been doing that and
obsessing over that since he was in
fifth grade since it was meant to do it
for she's been drawing cartoons and and
then you know asking teachers girls the
his wife is the voice silikal is Meg
yeah Mila Kunis she makes more money off
of that than anything she's ever done I
bet man they make some and then the set
you have seen I was way the Simpsons
people make oh my god
I know it's [ __ ] crazy the only
healthy family guys killing it you know
Adam West's Batman had just died it was
the voice you used the the mayor west he
was yeah he's mayor west just Seth
MacFarlane's had such a passion for
Batman oh wow
add Wes he gave him a job as mayor west
girl because I love Adam West I raised
you right yeah what else get in all
right so this one I'm not really I don't
know this one that last Regina I know
this one's very well go ahead go ahead
look at the amount of plastic surgery
she's had so Rob Kardashian who dated a
girl named blac chyna he's posted her
about to drop some knowledge on pictures
of her vagina derivative some other
stuff online like for everyone to see
I'm pretty honest I'm very could bring
it Rob Kardashian into hostess pictures
of her can I bring her up let me let me
put this all out for you guy know your
body's ridiculous you guys know my work
there's someone to work at but who cares
so check it so Rob Kardashian her have a
child together right yet never baby so
she's a stripper she known for being
promiscuous she has a son with in the
fall me here with Kylie's boyfriend Tyga
they're broken up now but so they're all
kind of [ __ ] each other
let's serve so he has a son with just
son with hurt with Rob's
sister's ex-boyfriend so [ __ ] weird
okay so check out she's known for being
promiscuous right so then Rob finds out
listen to this they have a daughter
together she leaves him after the
daughter after they have the baby she
just takes all the ship moves out so
then Rob starts a blast on Instagram and
he goes because she sends him a video
she goes home have a good day Rob and
this is on Instagram and it's a picture
of her Geum ready to [ __ ] this dude
she's making out this black dude and she
goes hope you have a good day Rob so he
freaks out now and then she talks about
how in her in their house how she's had
all these guys busting her like three
different dudes a day just [ __ ] her
why ten there's pictures of her with
these dudes
and they're in Rob's robes oh my god and
Rob's like how the [ __ ] can you do this
and but this is a thing ice China hum
China's not even like she's like in with
this what you [ __ ] signed up for the
prom Rob looks like such a
[ __ ] because he's like complaining and
he's blasting all the [ __ ] out and first
of all why are you dating her are you a
girl we go like this new guy came out
was like dude what'd you think was gonna
happen you're dating a [ __ ] yeah and
then yeah and then she's [ __ ] this
this random black dude who's like broke
and in Rob in him have with him and Rob
or having a text conversation Rob post
the text conversation the dude goes man
[ __ ] this girl let's both [ __ ] her and
get this money and he's like what droite
that's the [ __ ] mothered by childhood
eat I'm your father to his child is the
word you dummy you don't have you don't
have a child with that that crazy
psychopath now you're stuck and this is
this is what's raising your child this
is the human being that's raising
outrages that this is who's raising your
kid I wouldn't believe all gods [ __ ] he
goes the plastic surgery I know he goes
yields after after you had the baby he
goes after yeah the baby room was like
God she bounced back so fast because I
paid a hundred grand for your stomach in
your ass and your tits what he's talking
about a hundred crazy man but Rob's
don't worry losses in this black child
like everyone knew I was kind of a [ __ ]
like what do you want me to acknowledge
it nothing she has a restraining order
against it she did she just embraces
she's got a restraining her but what
about his child does he get to see his
two kid yeah well his thing is he's like
you will never see our daughter okay so
he's got full custody he's gonna get
full sessi like his lawyers obscene yeah
Carly time a Kardashian money and he's
paying her rent because I paid 16 K a
month for your [ __ ] rent and you
[ __ ] these dudes and let him bust
inside that actually she [ __ ] up
because he can pull all that awake I
mean that that's grounds for well
they're not married either okay
Wow well hey Rob you dummy Rob's not
doing Rob's put on some elby's well yeah
but he's not he's I think he suffers
from depression he's never really found
his groove off his sisters or what they
are like he's in his stepdad turned into
a woman you don't think your sister's
[ __ ] dudes now your baby mamas
[ __ ] every dick slapping hairy around
the corner you have a kid with her she's
cheating on you two over 30 times they
say there's a baby in the house
in the same house and and you're saying
that is everybody in her like what she
says that I'm milking and then there's
pictures of these dudes that are busting
inside of her with his robes on he goes
oh that's my [ __ ] Rosati Rome she's
like I know all over there what an adios
you got that out of my laundry dirty lot
an awful woman why would she what also
deserves lots of the dudes to the dudes
of dudes who are like I'm banging yeah
in a house I mean guys are like what all
right Versace robot I get my dick about
I mean I got a you know I get that they
don't care they don't know that dude but
but like she in in his home click on
this one from each injustice show bra
like she's not a bad-looking creature no
I'm not that professional not let me
shed hair yeah I mean that she's a dime
piece she's super artificially created
yet is that as free I want to kick real
nice really late I wouldn't kick her out
bed for eating hot cheetos okay that
much now I mean it was picture she looks
great but she's such a horrible person
that see that's tough what a terrible
person
I didn't know that backstory so him
posting the pictures of her vagina
online that's going way too far though
right
Instagram but I needed his account put
his put his count on freeze you can't
post native pictures like it doesn't end
well for blac Chyna it doesn't light as
well for their yeah no I put life you'll
master that child they brought into the
world I feel bad for Rob to like he's
looking for approval he thought it was
with this black China if kids go um the
[ __ ] she probably that's not a smart
guy move is it that's just not very
smart
that's a desperate move looking at I
think he wants a family like not like
work with his Diane I to get closer to
that yeah there you go nice guy feel bad
for me he's really close to Lamar Odom
who was like a brother to him and Lamar
dies you know basically remark I didn't
know almost is but you had in that try
how was he doing do we know not good
that's it's not [ __ ] good so he's
supposed to be a really nice like
everyone in Rob's life is gone and then
think about your surround by your mom's
this media [ __ ] your sis got famous for
[ __ ] black guys on tape yeah and
you're in that culture yeah of course
he's gonna suffer
I've missed you realistic
just girl like some he just it's just
suck him he just want something to like
a man you know she you know she's a
hypnotist and if you know she'll [ __ ]
you like like she loves you yeah you
know in his sisters like you realize
she's just doing this to get on the show
and he's like no she loves me and then
they told him like dude can we you can
see his rather women but we're sure
especially those women could they know
the game but II was going to give Rob in
China their own show which I think they
did for a season and Kim and the rest of
the credits are like no don't do it man
but they're like he needs money like
this is you will get paid serious money
from this it's a [ __ ] show man well I
know some trout have no idea how did you
get you that's that's my girls into it
so I hear all this stuff I feel like Kim
she'd just given ten known it would
probably they do they know he know he
has a shitload of money yet you know
there's that that said yeah and he's
been funny how it doesn't matter you got
nowhere to go
he's got nowhere to put his energy these
doesn't have even have that he knows he
has no career his muddy house yeah it
doesn't have any of this crap queen of
his baby mama Queen what else you got
chin alright Gaby Garcia had a fight
recently and you know who Gabi Garcia is
she's one of the biggest like buffest
Brazilian players and where does anime
now yeah let's say on courts illegal
yeah
so this is all created and up fight and
she while just show these discs Whipple
quick oh my god and then you know she's
last time she fought a really old woman
old grandma oh my god this is only
supposed to be a stand-up fight who the
[ __ ] is she fighting so some Japanese
woman I'll show you that side-by-side so
she drops her in it's soccer kicks her
which is completely illegal so she got a
no contest or disqualification but this
is them okay so why is why is that girl
fighting it's in Japan there's like
Japan my time she's bigger - it shows so
this is literally them sending each
other's this game II have um giantism a
form kind to them or something I think
that and I know I'm not a hundred
percent sure but I'm thinking she does
yeah you could
later on I hear she's a really nice
person I'm sure she's a I've never met
her sounds really very hard to be that
big I'm sure yeah that's not an easy
life right now I'm sure it's very hard
for her super hard I were you I would
not wish on my daughter and hopefully
she's happy I asked to her she's a
really nice person I don't know we're
sure she's a very nice person
yeah her she and you know that kick
that's like in the heat of combat I
don't know when him tell why she was on
yes like it wasn't like a crow cop Ron
Waterman yeah that's what I like that
girl's going down to cakes right I got
[ __ ] right
but awesome doesn't matter he's a giant
she could have flicked him right Alex
O'Connor I think she's my height 6-3
she's sideboards main trading partner
really mmm Wow
is there any footage of em sparring okay
six to 209 pounds
I'll take click on that which she lost
all that weight though look at that she
looks amazing there do UFC when she
could be introduced that's that's gotta
be steroids right Bob uh I mean I'm not
gonna make accusation no idea know when
strong something I don't I've no idea
she looks great there we go we got her
when she competed in jujitsu though look
at that
that's what Wanderlei Silva cast natural
um he said you Jitsu
yeah field hurt their be picture her and
she said literally no one could be like
I don't think that Mackenzie Darren
beater out here they're glad is when
that servers are gender yeah a big I
mean look at the size of her though yeah
that's like absolutes you know like they
don't win their division then we go that
far left one where she's a Nagina
bathing so you see it psychic yeah right
up Amanda yeah
look at that Wow good for her losing all
that good right there right so I feel
that your study
I can almost I can almost get with that
a little to Moscow from and date I've
heard nothing but great things about it
to be honest with you I'm sure I don't
know her you know I've been I've been
too harsh on her but I you know she's
she's just a very big girl but is she's
also buried a guilt to go and I yeah
very skilled I'm sure very skill I'm
sure she's why for martial artists yeah
let monster Jitsu and I don't think I
feel the dirtiest giant giant isn't
she's just a bear I don't think she does
did you look at her when she cook all
that way
yes yes what does she get - just a big
girl yeah no were that polo ever again
he's bigger than Aniston cell phone if
you pull that that picture back up and
Anderson Silva's tall I mean that's I
forget which one I clicked on I've stood
next to Anderson Silva he is tall she's
tall him him so it was about 6 - yeah
well here she is with Alistair there she
is she's not small no anywho anything
looks interesting
all right did you guys see Prince
Charles and is the Duchess laughing
during a throat-singing
presentation performance I mean being
human Kylie we have to laugh you're I
will they are dying right laughs I would
last they are precise teams design video
of it yes this is Amelia please if you
guys smell I gotta laugh this let's try
not to laugh this is funny traditional
Inuit throat but I need dying I would be
what I will my brawl out of my chai
intraday booth I don't care but didn't
even answer about that she doesn't know
[ __ ] traditional up so you hey you're
gonna go like that and I'm dead cereal
after and lock eyes with each other you
guys and then look like a [ __ ] Eskimo
Adele I'm a laughing my ad I look at
this booth that is so funny to me say
they have a right to laugh at that
obviously is [ __ ] she's died a play
they get informative
I gotta want to see there's like a long
video somewhere but there's not a
shorter one you and I would be dying we
didn't try to get in beat
oh my god hey you know what first my
view start laughing always how long do
they go for it I think it was a few
minutes oh my god that's terrible yeah
but let's not do that
at the after the footage is post online
youtuber user comments who who gives a
flying [ __ ] about user comments goes how
disrespectful their laughing was
incredibly rude extremely rude and
disrespectful on both their parts an
appalling lack of respect you guys are
out of your mind I thought it was
hilarious what do you expect from them
no and then I read more about it I guess
in that throat scene thing where you
have two people the person that laughs
first is the one that loses so there's
it's like a game sometimes like at
things funding all these critics that is
worthy of laughter I could never keep a
straight face my name if you ever heard
and by the way ready for this everybody
that singing is [ __ ] okay go I'm
sorry that it's indigenous to [ __ ] it
[ __ ] you I agree I spent time of the die
axe in [ __ ] Indonesia
go [ __ ] yourself just because it's
indigenous doesn't mean I can't laugh in
it and just because it's indigenous
doesn't mean it's not [ __ ] okay
because it is so [ __ ] off so sick of
this I'm so sick anything that's like
original and indigenous to that culture
is untouchable yeah okay how about widow
strangling how would you go eat some
dead in a seal Weiner uh you know she
got you let's see what else he knows the
looters guys oh this 19 year old
California girl she won the lottery
twice and they're not small jackpots in
the same week that how the [ __ ] does
that happen
one was five hundred fifty five thousand
and then the same week she bought
another one for a hundred thousand God
yeah that's pretty crazy nineteen years
old - this is trending story brave woman
grabs anaconda from middle of Brazilian
Road that's pretty cool I thought he
videos probably down yeah videos down
sorry that's what's kept me all good
then I'm hiding it
that idiom that oh wait one more I want
to show you guys I didn't know this but
did you know that the ESPN photo of
Tiger Woods was photoshopped - now how
so so you saw this is the actual photo
when he looks pretty his eyes I hold in
nobody and this is the ESPN floor that
they put out tonight can look better so
that's the thing people were criticizing
it and then ESPN said they had to do
this because of their template and how
it they wanted it to fit inside this
little box that's wrong with that but
also they dusted only well he didn't do
they didn't want to make him look bad
either they must like a woods man you
know he's a face you know he was I no
idea how much content get for your spin
but also this goes both ways so right so
they made him look better there who
gives a flying [ __ ] but also with OJ
Simpson of them in with darker almost
covers on the cover of Time magazine
you know they actually shade him so he
looked at super a more ominous more and
more black yeah
good but you look at that reflection
look at them don't go Jake Sims imagine
coming there be before-and-after there
you go right there
look gone yeah right look at these
there's time and there's the real
picture look at them
oh crap to make them super more cuz they
wanted to look more like a mini you are
more ominous more like actual black bow
they do it both ways men they're not
doing it you know there's no [ __ ]
filters and take mug shot yeah you only
take passport photos or not that I got
no smiling no grinning like Jesus cried
yeah and I was like shitty CJ's he
should 100 so not be allowed to fly
after pictures I was like okay you look
like a pure terrorist because I know I
don't have to do okay well don't look
don't have your face look like that
don't have less being Isis they don't
don't do that
you have resting Isis your face resting
terrorist face it's a real problem
alright man thanks I am dropping
knowledge drop these nuts in your
[ __ ] mouth no you I had a really
interesting way of putting something I
think wall over Baldwin Peterson my hero
said we should be teaching our kids to
worry less about their rights and more
about personal responsibility and we
live in a culture it seems especially in
academia where people like to category
rise the world as victims and oppressors
good guys bad guys is kind of what
ideologies do they don't really leave
room for anything in-between they allow
for people who are either right or the
other people that are the enemy and who
are wrong and that's always a very
dangerous way of looking at things and
when you say that we should really have
a body that enforces rights as opposed
to taking personal responsibility you're
relying on a third party to give you
those rights and how has that worked out
in this country for people who are less
advantaged yes you can pass laws and
enforce rights but really you are your
best bet to get yourself out of a
situation you don't want to be in it's
tough to accept a lot of times but it's
just the truth it's just a good policy
there are exceptions to that rule but
for the most part always accept that
policy the danger that we're in is when
you hear when you listen to public
discourse people if you frame like
Thomas solo who is a black scholar I
believe out of Harvard and he's written
several books one of which was black
rednecks white liberals and he suggests
that part of the problem for example in
Chicago where a hundred people died were
shot over the 4th of July weekend if you
were to say well maybe there's something
in that culture that Chicago ghetto
culture that's lending itself to this
kind of violence and the solutions might
let rest in those people in those
communities figuring out what's wrong
with their culture and addressing those
problems if you brought that up in a lot
of liberal circles in a lot of academic
circles you would be and Thomas Sowell
has you would be shouted out of the room
because what you're doing is saying that
there might be some personal
responsibility in there but the liberal
narrative in academia nowadays is you've
got to have an oppressor it's got to be
somebody else's fault not their fault
it's somebody else's fault and if we
take the oppressor out of the equation
then all the people that are oppressed
will come up and there won't be anymore
oppressors it is a rudimentary and
ridiculous [ __ ] idea
human beings are tribal human beings
have
take responsibility for themselves you
will never stop oppression prejudice
tribalism bigotry because that's how
people behave when Manny Pacquiao fights
crime goes down in the Philippines all
right why is that because Filipinos are
prejudiced is that because Filipinos are
would rather they do want to see
somebody it looks and talks like them
beat up the guy that doesn't that
doesn't make them even pro Filipino it
makes them human so that's an important
thing so personal responsibility more
important than your rights that's what I
have to say I hope that resonates with
all you kids out there good stuff
thank you Doug bless you did you get
that buddy a little so a little bit of a
moment of silence there god bless you
thank you now I want you to muzzle my
dick why God did I just came up with
over there out all of them I don't I'm
not gonna muzzle it old face
I'm knock that blood and muscle this
dick no you're out aha like freaking out
we've been here a while buddy let's get
her house let's go eat some food and get
get have our meeting all right on the
roof your bottom teeth up okay love you
guys this is the farm kid we're out yeah